hey it's Alex and today I'm gonna show
you how to make my chocolate fudge
brownie cheesecake so this was actually
the first cheesecake I ever did for
tasty so I guess you could say was the
cheesecake that started it all I really
love cheesecake so when I was developing
this recipe what I was really looking
for with some really beautiful layers
and the flavor is pretty easy I mean
what's better than chocolate fudge
brownie and cheesecake so the bottom of
this 3 layer of cheesecake is the
brownie arguably the best later I chose
to make the brownie layer out of box
brownie mix but feel free to make your
own brownie recipe if you choose to just
makes it a little easier
so the second layer is the Cheesecake of
course I chose to do a classic baked
cheesecake recipe so we're gonna have to
double bake this cheesecake because you
have to bake this cheesecake twice a lot
of people were worried that the brownie
layer would actually burn or get too
hard by the time the whole cheesecake is
done baking but don't worry the
cheesecake layer creates a sort of a
barrier and keeps your brownie really
fudgy and moist and if you really wanted
to you could swap out the cheesecake
layer for a no-bake cheesecake and just
pop it in the fridge after your brownie
is been baking but I will always prefer
a baked cheesecake to a no-bake
cheesecake so a springform pan is really
useful because the sides release so it's
great for like a softer cake like a
cheesecake when you don't want to mess
up the sides and stuff so you just
release I might be describing this well
you just okay you just open the clip on
the side and lift it up and you're ready
to go in case your cheesecake rocks a
little bit on the top don't worry we're
gonna cover it in our third layer which
is the beautiful chocolate ganache also
very delicious so chocolate ganache
sounds scary to make but it's super
super easy and it's delicious and very
beautiful all you have to do is melt
down your chocolate with hot heavy cream
and mix it until it creates a beautiful
silky mixture once all the chocolate is
melted you're ready to go this moment
where I drizzled the chocolate ganache
over the cheesecake one of my proudest
tasty moments so the easiest way to do
this blades is to move the cake onto a
rack on a baking sheet so when you pour
over the chocolate ganache it runs off
into the pan instead of all over your
tables out of all of the videos I've
made I still go back to this shot
because it's so beautiful just the way
the chocolate drips over the cheesecake
[Music]
and if you want to since nothing should
go to waste you can take the rack off
and or back any of the like residual
chocolate ganache into a bowl pop it in
the fridge eat it later
the chocolate ganache creates a
beautiful silky shiny layer on the
outside that will be sure to impress
anybody you're trying to impress
I am Bria and this is my recipe for rock
crab cake so a few years ago there was a
trend where you roll up apple slices
onto a pastry and made a little turret
so I was wondering if there was anything
I could make that would look pretty like
that and I came up with this idea using
crepes instead of Pesce I wasn't sure if
it's gonna walk first but I tried it
anyway and when I think of crepes my
favorite filling its strawberry and
whipped cream so instead of apples I
decided to use strawberries the
important thing about making crepes is
wasted dough for at least 30 minutes
because we are mixing with milk and
flour which creates gluten and you don't
want to make chewy and rubbery crepes if
you want you can also rest in overnight
and make it the next day
I chose cream cheese filling because
it's a little thicker so easy to work
with
you are ending up making a bunch of
crepes for this recipe and that will
take time but I also think it's fun as
well so I tested this and made a pretty
small version that was really really
cute but when I make the tart I usually
want to share so I don't want to make it
just for myself when you're making at
home it's a little bit messy because
you're spreading cream onto the crepe
and rolling it up but it's what's there
for and most of men because it's really
pretty and I'm sure whoever you're going
to give it to will be super impressed
make sure to cut the strawberry it's
very thin it's similar to a crepe cake
because it's layered about just a
different presentation because the
crepes are vertical instead of fries on
top
so instead of stopping making small
little toy I was just kept rolling and
rolling and rolling and I ended up
making a large crepe cake
I think rolling it up it's the most fun
and difficult particles it's kind of
like building a snowman it's the same
cake all the way through it just gets
bigger also after you make this roll the
crepe a big enough then you can't start
laying it on the side instead of rolling
then what you end up with it's a super
pretty roll of crepes all standing up
with strawberry it's kind of looking
like a flower which is why I call this a
rose crepe cake this is the perfect
dessert to bring down afternoon people
ready or just to make with your friends
sometime I was filming this recipe late
at night because I wasn't sure if it's
gonna work so I was kind of testing and
shooting at the same time and Alex and
Scott was also shooting late at night so
we shared together and both of them are
impressed so this recipe it's something
I'm really proud of because I've never
seen this type of cake before so I would
like you to make it and I also want you
to be proud of it
[Music]
hey I'm Alvin I'm a tasty producer and
today I'll be showing you how I came up
with my recipe for the five layer
brownie cookie cheesecake five layer
brownie cheesecake was probably one of
my greatest architectural feats if I
would say so myself I was actually
studying engineering in college not
really a good student to be honest but
one thing that I definitely needed pick
up was the ability of how to approach a
problem and how to look at it from
certain angles especially when things
don't exist a lot of times we are asked
to do hypothetical questions like if you
wanted to accomplish this how would you
go about achieving it and I learned that
the easiest way is to break down the
problem into its parts and kind of
almost work backwards cookie dough Oreos
and brownies are very common combination
and I wanted to take that further I
really wanted to turn the flavor profile
of like a triple stacked brownie into
something else I wanted to turn it into
more of like this spectacle dessert that
you could really wow everybody at a
party with and I just absolutely love
layers and clean layers so that was
something that I set out to do was to
turn a triple-decker brownie into a
cheesecake the challenge with this
recipe is that all of these elements all
bake at different times different
temperatures and have different
thicknesses I kind of wanted to go after
your vibe of when you go to Cheesecake
Factory and they set down this slice of
this beautifully cut and assembled
cheesecake I really didn't know how this
was gonna go until I made it and I had
to do a lot of pre-planning and thinking
and being able to try to predict how the
food would behave in a way that I had
never done before
I was hoping that the brownie batter
would not get dry I guess that the cream
cheese and the mixture would give the
brownie moisture it was really
gratifying to pull something like this
off especially when you have never
really done this before I guess I've
been really happy relieved that it
actually worked
after the brownie and cheesecake were
set that's when I put the Oreos and the
cookie dough on top
I don't try to do recipes a lot of times
because I think I really enjoy the
challenge of getting it right on the
first to the second try kind of
nerve-wracking to cut it open because
you really don't know how it's gonna
turn out until you actually slice it
open into the layers and to my luck it
really worked out well I was able to see
all four elements in their entirety I
love to spend time just thinking about
the food and really just trying to guess
and predict how food is going to behave
and sometimes I really just sit down and
write things down and try to map out our
draw out how certain food to look before
and after and so for this one I thought
about it a lot and made some decisions
and that's the sort of approach that I
like to take because there's something
really cool about trying something
that's completely new and then somehow
landing it on the first try what
combination of desserts do you want me
to attempt next
[Music]
I think that's it hopefully it's good yo
[Music]